my mother to keep her house in long
island
rents the house out did i go into this
i don't remember okay like she left
people come in she
rents rooms out in the house and who's
renting
rooms in houses drug dealers
so they move into my house and
by the way if you've ever had your
mother
rent rooms to cocaine dealers when
you're in eighth grade
and you know how convenient it is
it's just easy it's so
convenient to buy cocaine at
breakfast which was what i was doing i
was watching a drug dealer made flip
pancakes
and then we would do lives so but it was
a good
time i know i hear you
if it was all bad i would tell you drugs
drugs work cigarettes work
cigarettes are like ninety dollars the
package is like it kills you no one
cares
it just so that the drugs don't work
forever
and there's other things you should do
instead of them
yes but i mean this was an era but are
these people you
know of yes i know they're from my town
i know them from my town
i remember hanging out in my town one
day and some guy going we're going to
buy an ounce of weed
we're going to 269 madison avenue which
is where i used to live and there and
i'm like can i get a ride with you
and like are you buying something there
i said i live there
and they're like really i was like yeah
i
would walk into a house and see my
mother and and and big
drug dealers from my town i mean not the
shinaloa cartel but big for long island
yeah right
eating baked clam and this was the time
just of really great baked clams
really good really good long island
seafood and i would walk in and be like
hi
mom hi drug dealer i've known for a long
time eating baked clams
you know she rented a room to a guy
named dennis who was not a drug dealer
but he was uh he loved to drink and i in
my show the tim dillon show i've told
the story a bunch
and it's become like the de facto uh
saying of my show life in the big city
because dennis no matter what you said
to dennis he would just go life in the
big city
um and and like we my mother said to him
once you know your kids haven't spoken
to you in five years
uh they called the other day you were
drunk and you answered the fun drunk and
they hung up and now they don't want to
speak to you ever again
and dennis would go he would have a
burger king cup with wine in it and ice
wine and marlborough reds and he would
go life in the big city
you know my mother would go the house is
going to be foreclosed on you're going
to be homeless
life in the big city he lived in her van
for six months after
six months six months after and he would
say to us he'd go hey
i'm living in a van that's life in the
big city what was great about this i'm
pretty sure dennis had never been to a
city
he'd never other than like vietnam or
wherever he went
but that's not a city but you know what
i mean like i think that might have been
the biggest city
um but he had a great attitude about
the the the trials and tribulations of
life the waves that hit us
all he would say life in the big city
you know oh you lost your job life in
the big city
uh your brother hates you because he's
accusing you of stealing his money
life is a big thing he did he was a
great like i i appreciated the way he
just rolled
right off of that breeze through it all
you know it's it really is a way to go
and he died as most people
that are like him do uh shark fishing in
montauk he just
swear to god he clutched his heart one
day on the boat and it was over
and these are the things
these are the these are the stories
but show so wait i mean so many goddamn
questions here
is your mom also using at the time no
she's
and she kind of knows that they are
doing something and she know
you're using she's from them she knows
that i'm like smoking pot she doesn't
know that i'm buying it there she has a
inkling that i'm smoking pop but she's
also schizophrenic so she's all over the
place
like i i remember one time we had
dropped acid from from the guy upstairs
and and she was screaming what's wrong
with your eyes i can't believe what is
wrong with you and then she just started
screaming i can't believe i'm with all
these drug addicts
drug addicts alcoholic trigger and
dennis just opened his door
and said patty it's just acid shut the
[ __ ] up
he goes shut up he go you'd ruin
anyone's trip get the [ __ ] in your room
and i went this guy
really is an advocate of mine
[Music]
you